-My first guest is a multiple
Grammy-nominated artist
and one of the most talented
people on the planet.
Her new album, "Dancing With the
Devil: The Art of Starting Over"
is out now.
And her documentary
"Demi Lovato:
Dancing With the Devil"
is streaming on YouTube.
Here's my BFF.
I love her.
Demi Lovato!
[ Laughs ] That's what
I'm talking about.
Yeah! Come on.
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
-Oh, you look great, bud.
Oh, before we get into it too,
I thought you were fantastic
at the inauguration --
-Thank you.
-...doing "Lovely Day."
That was -- Knock out.
That was one of my favorites.
The last time
you were on the show,
we were talking about
what you're into.
And you were saying that
you were into painting,
and we did portraits
of each other.
-Yes.
-Do you remember this?
-Yes. Yes.
-And I think I did okay.
Here was my portrait
I did of you.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Do you remember this?
-Yeah. Oh, yeah. Killer.
Really, really good.
-I stopped at -- I didn't think
could I master the eyes.
Cause, you know --
-I should have taken a note.
-No, I just thought your eyes,
they're too pretty
for me to paint.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you.
-And I did get a lot of hate,
by the way --
a little hate
for my name being so large.
I don't know how to do -- sign.
-[ Laughs ]
-I signed it really big.
But then your portrait of me,
I thought was --
I thought it was pretty good.
I liked this, actually.
This is --
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
I thought it was fantastic.
I was thinking of, like,
sending it to you.
And then I go, "Well, you're not
going to hang up
a portrait of yourself."
So I don't know what really
to do with it, but I would -- -
-Jimmy, if you sent it to me,
I would absolutely hang it up
in my house.
-You would?
-Yes, absolutely.
You painted a portrait of me.
How could I not?
-Okay. Very good. Alright.
Then I'm going to send it
to you. Alright.
Next time you come on, I want to
see it hanging somewhere.
Pal, I want to talk about your
album, "Dancing With the Devil."
It is fantastic, by the way.
-Thank you.
-Really, it's unbelievable.
'Cause the documentary --
I watched it,
and I'm just not
going to get emotional,
but it is rough and tough.
You know, I love you, and good
for you for doing this thing.
And was it odd to go that honest
about your life
and talk about your life
straight to camera
and tell every single secret?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
It was very --
It was challenging
because everything
that I went through
in that storytelling journey
of making a documentary
was difficult.
And I had to work through
a lot of those things
before I actually
told the story on camera.
But I've been working on,
you know, my --
I've been working on myself
and putting in a lot of work
behind the scenes
so that when it was time
to put it on camera,
I felt completely secure
in telling my story.
And it's been really cathartic,
really, really therapeutic.
And I'm just hoping that
a lot of people can learn
from what I went through
and also, you know,
create conversation
around those topics.
-Yeah. It already is.
It already is happening.
Have you --
Have you watched this,
or can you even watch this
or no?
-So, I watched it when the,
like, first cut was ready.
Since then, I've seen it,
like, three or four times maybe.
But, yeah, it was challenging.
It was challenging.
I had, like, a physical reaction
the first time
that I watched it,
like, anxiety attack.
But -- But it's been --
it's been good.
And a part of, you know, telling
my story is taking ownership.
-Yeah.
-And not --
And just owning my truth.
No matter what people say
when they watch it,
it doesn't matter.
And listen to my album.
Whatever people think
when they listen to my album,
I am so excited
about these two projects,
and I'm standing in such truth
that nothing that anyone
can say can shake me.
-What a record, by the way.
What an album.
-Thank you.
-It's unbelievable.
Obviously, I love
the title track,
"Dancing With the Devil."
Just knocked it out of the park.
It is fantastic.
-Thank you.
-I'm going to tell you
something.
I don't know if you know this.
It is the biggest female
pop album debut of the year.
Congrats on that.
-That's good.
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I'm talking about!
See what I'm talking about, pal?
Come on!
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Both laugh ]
Also, you know what I love?
I love that jam, I love --
I love a lot of them.
I like "Met Him Last Night"
with Ariana Grande.
-So Ariana and I have known
each other for several years.
And when she first came out
with her song, "The Way,"
years ago, I heard that
and was like,
"This girl is such a vocalist."
And I'm such a fan.
So we met,
and ever since that day,
we've talked about
wanting to do a song together.
But, you know,
it just never happened.
And she's just been someone
that's been really,
really supportive of my career.
But when it came time
for this album,
I played her some of the songs.
I played her
"Dancing With the Devil."
And she started writing
this song with me in mind,
and she played it for me
and, you know, she was like,
"I have this song.
I'm want to help
share your story."
And I was like, "You sound
incredible on this.
You should stay on it,
and we can finally do
the song that we've always
wanted to do together."
-Yeah.
-So she was like, "Are you sure?
I was just going to be, like,
mystery harmony
background lady."
And I was like,
"No, you're Ariana."
-No, you're not. Yeah.
-"Let's sing. Let's go."
-Everyone will know it's you.
Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
It's fantastic, bud.
Congrats on this.
I want to talk more
and maybe play
a fun game with you
when we come back.
-Yes.
-But, first, I wanted to
show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at
"Demi Lovato: Dancing With
the Devil" on YouTube.
Take a look.
-I remember
being in my hospital bed
and thinking, "Alright.
How do I fix this?
How do I get back to doing what
I love, which is making music?"
-Demi is an honest songwriter.
A lot of people are nervous
about telling everything.
Demi thrives on using her music
in a cathartic way.
-I feel, like, with "Anyone,"
I knew that was a song
that I wanted to release
coming out of all of this.
Because I thought if I ever
make it back to the stage,
I want to sing this song.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about, bud!